So, as we explained, different
textual representation tends to enable
different analysis.
In particular, we can gradually add
more and more deeper analysis results
to represent text data, and that would
open up more interesting
representation
opportunities and also analysis
capacities.
So this table summarizes what we have
just seen.
So the first column shows the text
recognition, the second visualizes the
generality of such representation,
meaning whether we can do this kind of
representation accurate before all the
text data, or only some of them, and third
column shows the enabled analysis
techniques.
And the final column shows some
examples of application that can be
achieved through this level of
representation.
So let's take a look at them. So as a
string text can only be processed by
using stream processing algorithms, but
it's very robust, it's general.
And there are still some interesting
applications that can be done at this
level. For example, compression of text
doesn't necessarily need to know the
word boundaries.
Although knowing word boundaries might
actually also help.
Word based representation is very
important level of representation.
It's quite general and relatively
robust.
It can enable a lot of analysis
techniques such as word relation
analysis, topic analysis and sentiment
analysis, and there are many
applications that can be enabled by
this kind of analysis.
For example, Thesaurus discovery has to
do with discovering related words and
topic and opinion related applications
are abundant, and there are for
example, and people might be interested
in knowing the major topics covered in
the collection of text.
And this can be the case.
In research literature, a scientist
want to know what are the most
important research topics today or
customer service people might want to
know
what are the major complaints from
their customers about by mining their
email messages.
And business intelligence people might
be interested in understanding
consumers opinions about their products
and competitors products to figure out
the what are the winning features of
their products.
And in general there are many
applications that can be enabled by the
representation at this level.
Now moving down, we'll see
we can gradually add additional
representations. By adding syntactic
structures we can enable,
Of course, syntactic graph analysis.
We can use graph mining algorithms to
analyze
Syntactic graphs.
And some applications are related to
this kind of representation.
For example, stylistic analysis
generally requires syntactical
representation.
Syntactical structure representation.
We can also generate the structure
based feature features and those are
features that might help us classify
text objects into different categories.
By looking at the structures, sometimes
the classification can be more
accurate.
For example, if you want to classify
articles into
different categories
corresponding to different authors want
to figure out which of the
K authors has actually written this
article.
Then you generally need to look at the
syntactic structures.
When we add entities and relations,
then we can enable lot of techniques
such as knowledge graph analysis or
information network analysis in general
and this analysis would enable
applications
about entities, for example, discovery
of all the knowledge and opinions about
the real world energy entity.
You can also use this level
representation to integrate
everything about entity from scattered
sources.
Finally, when we add logic predicates
then we would enable logic inference
ofcourse, and this can be very useful for
integrative analysis of scattered
knowledge.
For example, we can also add ontology
on top of the extracted information
from text to make inferences.
A good example of application in this
enabled by this level of representation
is a intelligent knowledge assistant
for biologists.
And this is intended program that can
help biologists manage all the relevant
knowledge from literature about the
research problem, such as understanding
functions of genes.
And the computer can make inferences
about
some of the hypothesis that biologists
might be interesting, for example,
whether a gene has a certain function
and then the intelligent program can
read the literature to extract the
relevant facts.
Doing by doing information extraction
and then using a logical system to
actually track
that's the answers to researchers
questioning about what genes are
related to what functions.
So in order to support this level of
application, we need to go as far as
logical representation.
Now this course is covering techniques
mainly based on word based
representation.
These techniques are general and robust
and thus are more widely used in
various applications.
In fact, in virtually all the text
mining applications you need this
level of representation and the
techniques that support analysis of
texting this level.
But obviously all these other levels
can be combined and should be combined
in order to support sophisticated
applications.
So to summarize, here are the major
takeaway points.
Text representation determines what kind
of mining algorithms can be applied.
And there are multiple ways to
represent text - strings, words,
syntactic structures and the relation
graphs, logical predicates, etc.
And these different
representations should in general be
combined in real applications to the
extent we can.
For example, if even if we cannot do
accurately,
this application of syntactic
structures we can stick at partial
structures extracted and if we can
recognize some entities and that would
be great.
So in general we want to do as much as
we can.
And when different levels are combined
together, we can enable richer
analysis.
More powerful analysis.
This course, however, focuses on word
based representation.
Such techniques have also several
advantages.
First, they are general and robust, so they
are applicable to any natural language.
That's a big advantage over other
approaches that rely on more fragile
natural language processing techniques.
Secondly, it does not require much
manual effort or sometimes it does not
require any manual effort.
So that's again important benefit,
because that means you can apply
directly to any application.
Third, these techniques are actually
surprisingly powerful
and effective for many applications.
Although not all, of course, as I just
explained.
Now they are very effective, partly
because the words are invented by
humans as basic units for
communications.
So they are actually quite sufficient
for representing all kinds of
semantics.
So that makes this kind of word based
representation also powerful.
And finally such a word based
representation and the techniques
enabled by such a representation can be
combined with many other sophisticated
approaches.
So they're not competing with each
other.